an unprecedented natural disaster in New
Zealand's North Island entire towns have
been cut off by flooding and landslides
Farms houses and bridges have been
washed away
Cyclone Gabrielle has now passed with
the impact of the storm will be felt for
weeks to come
Wells
Devastation through the Dartmouth Road
it's all it's all headed so um
livelihood's lost what do you say really
it's a public the damage is with the
power lines as extensive and all our
Epley roads it's just snapped in so many
places so I think we'll be pretty cut
off for a while
more than 10 000 people have been
displaced and 140 000 left without power
on Tuesday a state of emergency was
declared only the third time in New
Zealand's history it's enabled the
government to move and resources from
across the country to help civil defense
efforts
our immediate Focus have has been
undertaking life-saving missions for
those affected by the floods who needed
to be rescued getting telecommunications
and power back on as quickly as possible
conducting aerial surveys to understand
the extent of the damage and to identify
where people need help
deploying emergency supplies food water
and medicine and getting Communications
assets to the areas that need them
the Cyclone follows floods in Auckland
and Auckland two weeks ago which were
triggered by record-breaking rains the
government says Now's the Time to
provide answers to climate change